why do you say the more people dislike
the antagonist the more they'll get
involved in the story I don't agree with
that so go
ahead I think that's a little I don't
know if we said that in the book did
we I think that's too simple
well let's put it this
way think of it
as you have you know we talked about two
basic factors you got your conflict you
got your character now Within
conflict
um you
have an antagonist who's going to
provide a big source of your conflict
and then you've got your protagonist
who's going to fight against it the
bigger the the the bigger the conflict
well how are you going to raise the
conflict one of the easiest ways is you
have a better and better
antagonist if the person is clever
ruthless creative it's a much more
interesting antagonist than big teeth
and a lot of saliva right but but again
if you if you want to make the the
conflict look
insurmountable and you know um I mean it
could be a fire breathing monster or it
could be a professor who is not going to
let you get your degree because your
work was too close to his you know
doesn't matter they can be equally
diabolical yeah and the more bad traits
you give them person the the more bad
things that person is willing to
do um the bigger your conflict is going
to be and again it could be very obvious
ruthless things or it could be very very
subtle things and sometimes the subtler
things are more Insidious because nobody
sees
them but it's still the the worse your
antagonist is the more you can raise the
stakes the more you can make the
conflict bigger um I'm going to go back
to die hard cuz I still think it's the
best movie in that
genre he was a great antagonist and what
made him great well two things one it
was brilliantly brilliantly the accent
brilliantly written it's all the accent
um well the thing about Alan Rickman is
he was a Shakespeare trained British
actor and done you know
State um I can almost tell in actor
who's worked on the stage from one who's
never worked on the stage but what they
wrote uh Stephen
Tusa um what he did which really
interesting is that he made the
antagonist as interesting if not more
interesting than the Bruce wellis
character and and there's a Twist you
think that they're terrorists if you
remember the movie you think they're
terrorists everybody else thinks thinks
they're terrorists but they're really
just Crooks Crooks and the Bonnie
bedelia's line in the movie is you're
just kind common thieves and he says and
it's right at the top of the third act
he says there is nothing common about me
Madam or
something I mean and he had the Thousand
suit the Armani th you know and you
understood him see that's the that's the
trap in villains is if you don't
understand the villain and you don't
care a little bit about how crazy and
evil they
are I don't think there's a
movie and the thing that I also love
about about that movie is he was playing
a psychological game with Bruce Willis's
character and that's the danger in
writing and I say this this is about
writing scripts not and you know novels
or plays or anything the danger is to
not make the antagonist which is what I
prefer to call them more more
interesting than your protagonist which
a lot of people will do in the early
drafts because protagonists are harder
to write flaws into because that's the
character typically the
writer identifies with right but I I
don't think that antagonist yes I mean I
think calling them just a villain limits
an act because I do a lot of talking now
about and I think it's really important
for writers to understand what's
playable in a scene and what's not so
actors will always say that you know how
am I going you say she's angry that's
not a playable thing how is she angry
how is she expressing that anger then
then an actor can start looking into
because they want to give that you know
especially today with all this great
stuff being written they want to do um
they want to really go into and find a
way into those characters this thing is
really interesting that I told you about
um gaslit the guy he's a very famous
character actor I can't think of his
name but he's playing Gordon lyy
probably one of the most evil people
that ever walked to the face of the
Earth and I saw an interview with him
and he said the script allowed me a
weighin and the weighin was his feelings
for his family so he wasn't he I mean
the guy was loved Adolf Hitler there
were all kinds of things about the real
Gordon lyy that are just he was in
too but he loved his family and that's
the way the actor went in writers have
to think about that when they're writing
they can't just write like you know a
kind of a stick figure character and say
a lot of writers I know and they're
starting they'll go well the actor will
fill that in now you good luck getting
an actor to play the role and when you
get to be a little bit more experienced
you start thinking about the the other
people who are get involved in this
collaborative experiment that you do
when you're on a show or a film is like
it's not just about you it's about
everybody you know you know the interior
exterior stuff and scripts I don't think
a lot of people realize that the last
person that matters to is the writer the
writer puts that in there for the set
designer for the cost you know all those
things are done for other people and I I
don't think that's taught it's not no
it's not just a thing to do what would
we need it we know the script we need to
know if it's interior or exterior we
need to know how many you know what are
the costumes what that's why you don't
write too much you don't do other
people's jobs for them but you help them
to maybe see the world that was what
William Goldman always said and I think
it's great don't don't design costumes
and don't cast the movie like what I
always have to tell students is don't
say he's
40 first of all what does 40 look like
and second of all casting records will
get so angry with you I you know a a
white man who's 40 what does that even
mean so imagination but I think you want
to be careful about making a
generalization never make a
generalization about the the nature of
an
antagonist right because there are some
antagonists who were just bad from the
beginning yeah everything about them is
bad and you hate everything they do and
they're really obviously evil terrible
people um that has the risk of being
cartoony right but it can also just be
such an evil person you know when you
have Hitler as your antagonist that's a
pretty good antagonist not such a nice
guy at least so I've heard um but
sometimes it's the guy that you don't
even realize as the anti an Agonist till
way later who's done things so subtly
and so small and so Insidious that
everybody's wondering why these terrible
things are happening and nobody can
identify the source and every point in
between so I think it's a decision you
make about the kind of script you're
writing
and you know if it's a war movie Hitler
is more interesting if it's uh um
somebody who really wants want a
degree um and she's never returned to
Professor's
favors um and can't get the degree by
it's a whole different thing and it can
be just as
Insidious yeah that doesn't really
contradict anything I'm saying I'm just
saying I say it it no I know I know but
it does but I just don't punch cuz I'm a
very delicate flower no no no all I'm
saying is no matter what you do do
dimensional
dimensionalize you know this is one of
the reasons that I'm not a fan of of
superhero movies except with a few
exceptions the Robert Downey ones are
great but but I'm thinking the way you
asked the question yeah made it sound
like well the more the more horrible and
I don't think that's necessarily true
right and it's it's the subtlety the
guile with which it's
done um the intensity I mean if you
think of all the different dimensions
you can be bad on it's a lot of
Dimensions you know I I had there was a
a
very very famous psychologist named
Albert Ellis who I had the the great
opportunity to spend a week doing a
practicum with him and he did a
interesting thing where he said
uh here's a desk can you measure
it and everybody said yeah that's easy
he just take take a tape measure no
that's measuring its length I want you
to measure the
desk say well what do you mean so well
how many ways can you measure a
desk well you could also do its weight
you could do its height you could do the
material it's made of you can do the
cache value of it its age its antique
value it's how many dimensions can you
measure and it starts to become near
infinite and then say now let's measure
a person
and when you start seeing all the
possible Dimensions you have to play
with and then there's an interesting
phenomenon in the psychology of problem
solving that when the dimension that
you're looking for to solve a problem is
the Salient Dimension it's very easy to
solve the problem when it's not Salient
it's very difficult so I would do a
demonstration with students where I'd
say um i' point to a black student and I
point to a white student say okay the
question is what's the difference
between these students and they'd say
well one is black one is white easy
because that's the first thing you
notice about them I do with an old
person a young person easy now I'd give
them another one where I'm looking at
are they wearing tennis shoes or leather
shoes what's the difference between
these people and there guessing all
sorts of crap and they don't get
anywhere close to the problem because
the dimension wasn't Salient it wasn't a
dimension you'd see
easily so if you think about using that
in your script and you start to say
let's not take the obvious thing how bad
is your super
weapon and rather how what's the subtle
power you have to stop this person all
of a sudden it becomes a totally
different script and it can be diabolic
or
than the other way of going about doing
it so you asked a you asked a very
profound question she's good at
that I have one thing to add I don't
want to forget this because it's in the
book and almost everybody told us this
and I think this is a relatively new
thing that people didn't ask 20 years
ago and Peter reminded me of it when he
was just talking about degrees of evil
and stuff see it's my fault actually
it's good thing you're going to be
you're if you're not asked they're not
doing their job the question I have when
somebody pitches is why you why now so
uh I think I think it's like if you
whether you bringing somebody an idea
for a product if you're going to an
entrepreneur whatever it's like why are
you the person to do this why are you
the person to write this script why are
you the person to do this
miniseries uh and it doesn't it's not
autobiographical I have a friend who's
doing a a
miniseries um about um a historical
princess that nobody knows anything
about and and it's a fascinating story
she's been researching this person for
10 years so that's something you would
say in a p you know I I think I think
the
more commitment they see from you the
more they see that you care the more
they'll care I mean because anybody can
pitch a story about some vague thing out
there so one of the things I think when
he's talk when Peter's talking about
degrees I
think you come up with a villain if you
want to call them a villain or an
antagonist use yourself use your life
don't don't try to write from Air I
think that that that's bad writing
you've got to use yourself who else do
you have that doesn't mean you have to
write
autobiography but we're all using
ourself no matter what we do and I think
that's where pictures very often go
south is people see you don't have a
personal commit you don't have the
passion and I didn't want to let the day
go without bringing that in because it's
really I think that's a really important
point and it it might
be why you're the person but you may not
have a personal direct connection with
the to
but you can talk about your fascination
with it and why you got interested in it
right so either way but
somehow one of the interesting points we
kept finding over and over again
is transmitting your enthusiasm for your
project right if you're not committed
and they don't see you having passion
for it why should
they and this is something that you
mention why did you write
this and what aspect of it got you so
excited right so you could be writing a
caveman
drama but if it's something about you
know I'm really interested in um
interpersonal conflicts and where do
they start when did people go from I
need to save my life do I need to
dominate
you that's okay whatever it is
but you need to think about a rationale
that was enough to pull you in and get
you excited and then your job is to say
how can I transmit this excitement right
to make somebody else curious
right